well we announced on timcast last night
we're going to launch a Public Square
Shark Tank Series so we're really stoked
about that so right now there's two
things happening in the country one is
that if you're an investor and you have
access to Capital uh you know we
complain about the George Soros of the
world as we should the guy is like run
by demons he's awful right the the dude
hates us and our families George sorus
is not a good dude neither is his son
and uh a lot of these people are putting
money toward the causes they believe in
and if you look at Wall Street today
it's largely run by SG and Dei dominated
Enterprises that have completely Left
Behind shareholder value so you've got
investors that are tired of that they
want to actually invest in companies
that believe in the future of the
country that they want to create that
are prioritizing meritocracy and
Excellence that aren't hiring because of
diversity quotas they're hiring for the
best candidates that's what investors
are looking for then on the other side
of things you have a group of businesses
that are starving for Capital